لذلك فقط فيما يتعلق
بمخاوفك المباشرة، من الواضح أن الوزير بلينكين
يحاول تنظيم
ممر إنساني سيكون من
الصعب جدًا التفاوض بشأنه الآن، أليس كذلك
مع الإسرائيليين لأنهم
يتحدثون عن حصار كامل أه ولكن
ما هو  أهم شيء
تحتاجه الآن حتى تتمكن من اجتياز
الأيام القليلة القادمة، ما هو مطلوب حقًا على الفور
هو التوصل إلى وقف لإطلاق النار أه للسماح
لأه سكان كازا بتلقي أه
الدعم والخدمات الأساسية على الأقل
للمسعفين  قادرون على
القيام ببعض الأعمال حول
مستشفياتهم، مستشفياتهم مليئة
بالإصابات، لا تزال هناك
إصابات في كل مكان،
لا توجد إمكانية الوصول
إلى المنظمات على الأرض
لتقديم الدعم، لا توجد قدرة
لسكان الولايات المتحدة  للتحرك والحصول على أه
الحصول على ما نحتاج إليه أو اه كما تعلم الحصول على
المياه التي نحتاجها أو الطعام الذي
نحتاجه نحتاج أه فوري أم
فوري لإطلاق النار حتى نتمكن
أيضًا من دعم أه أولئك الذين هم
تحت أه تحت  هذه
الظروف القاسية للغاية خاصة أولئك الذين يتخذون
ملاجئ في المدارس والذين
تتم استضافتهم في أماكن عشوائية جدًا
وأماكن عامة حول
القطاع، أنا كل شخص أعرفه شخصيًا
لا يعيش في منزله، كل شخص أعرفه
ينتقل من منزل واحد  من مكان إلى آخر
من مكان عام إلى منزل آخر إلى أحد
الأقارب الخ يجب إيقاف هذا
وأعتقد أنه سيكون
مقلقًا جدًا من حيث الإمدادات الغذائية
دخول الإمدادات الطبية أم أه
كل هذه العناصر الأساسية أه أقصد
بها  ساعة هناك
معاناة شديدة أه شديدة بالإضافة إلى
أه الموت الفعلي في في
المستشفيات أه نفسها
المكتظة أه بالإصابات
والضحايا من
التفجيرات أم من فضلك لا تكمل هذه
المقابلة إذا  تشعر أنك بحاجة إلى
الذهاب إلى مكان آخر من أجل سلامتك،
هل أنت بحاجة إلى المغادرة، لا
بأس، لا، أنا جيد، الأمر هكذا
طوال الوقت أم
نعم، أعني بالضبط هذا الصباح
كانت هناك غارة جوية ضخمة  في
مخيم الها وأه إنها صادمة للغاية
الصور وآمل أن هذه الصور
ستجعل الأخبار في أه في
قناتك أه على سبيل المثال حيث أه
يبدو أن هناك مذبحة ضخمة إنها
منطقة مكتظة بالسكان حيث
يوجد رفاق فقط تحتها  ركام أه أعني
أعتقد أن الوضع
حرج للغاية وأه التفاوض على
ممر آمن لست متأكدًا مما إذا كان هذا أه
سيكون فقط لإجلاء الأجانب أو أه
أو من أعني هذا لا
يستجيب حقًا لما أه ماذا سيكون
سيحتاج الناس بالطبع إلى
اهتمام بـ آه، كما تعلم، أريد فقط أن
أسألك عما تعلمه للتو، كما تعلم أنه من
الواضح أنه كان انفجارًا قريبًا جدًا
وجلست هناك
وواصلت
المقابلة آه بينما تعرف ما تريد
أعلم أن الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يشاهدونك سيفترضون
أنك ستهرب وتذهب إلى
مكان آمن، ولكن هل هذا لأنك ليس لديك
مكان تذهب إليه وأنك
معتاد على ذلك، فقط اشرح الملاجئ، شكرًا
لك تمامًا، شكرًا لك على
تربيتك  هذا يعني في
قطاع غزة بأكمله يعني ليس لدينا ملاجئ
أه يعني أفضل الظروف هي
أن تنزل إلى مستوى أقل أه تعلم
وأنا محظوظ جدا لدي سرداب
أه أين  ولهذا أستقبل أكثر
من 12 شخصًا بالإضافة إلى عائلتي
أه الذين هم جميعًا الآن أستضيفهم في
منزلي وبالتالي لا يستطيعون
العودة إلى منازلهم لأنهم
تضرروا بشدة  منطقة الرمال التي
كانت بيضاء اه ونحن تمكنا من
العيش معًا لذلك كلما كان هناك
شيء تعرفه قريبًا أو كبيرًا
مثل هذا، كما تعلم اه
نتجول في الممرات ثم
نذهب ببطء إلى الأسفل  المستوى وما إلى ذلك
ونحن نلتصق ببعضنا البعض وهذا
ما حدث في الساعة 5:00 صباحًا هذا الصباح
على سبيل المثال عندما كانت هناك غارات جوية ضخمة
تحدث بالقرب من الدعم G
أم والغرب في الجانب الغربي
من المدينة أه عبر الجانب الآخر  في
الشارع الذي كنت فيه، كان هناك
المبنى الذي كان مدمرًا بالكامل وكان علينا
إخلاءه وغادرنا آه نركض
بشكل أساسي معي في منتصف
الليل بعد الساعة الواحدة صباحًا منذ ليلتين وكنا
جميعًا في العشرين من عمري  منزل
20 2022 شخص أه الذين فروا من
منطقتهم جاءوا إلينا ثم انتقلنا ونقلنا
جميعًا إلى مكان مختلف وانقسمنا
إلى مكانين مختلفين مكانين أعني
أنك نتحدث عن موقف مجنون
هنا وضع مجنون تمامًا
نيل شكرًا لك  شكرًا جزيلاً
لانضمامك إلينا هذا الصباح، من الواضح أن
أولويتك هي مساعدة هؤلاء الأشخاص
وهؤلاء المدنيين ولكن من الواضح أن
هذه هي حياتك أيضًا وقد رأينا
ذلك الإسبريسو اليوم،
حظًا موفقًا بما تفعله وأشكرك
على ذلك.  تخصيص الوقت
شكرا لك شكرا لاستضافتي